going back to Philip Roth again seeing
interviews with him toward the later
years of his life he had moved from New
York City to sort of the Connecticut
woods to be left alone and all of the
journalists said isn't it lonely here
for you and he said it is but I enjoy it
there's no there's no friction there's
nothing because I guess he guess it was
after port noise complaint or one of the
he was just receiving so much attention
and he was bombarded with people's
opinions and this was just an easier way
for him to continue and I know this is a
common thing of sort of taking yourself
off the map so that you can create but
yet the loneliness was worth it versus
the friction yeah and obviously it
worked for him because other people who
would go off to live in the woods end up
not being productive because they they
think that's gonna solve their problem I
mean I learned this the hard way because
I had to finish a book early in my
academic career and I decided I'd go to
my parents late college or the summer
and just sit there and finish it and of
course I almost got nothing done that
summer because one thing led to the
other people would stop by to visit
because there was the lake and you know
the lawn would need attending or the
cabin itself needed fixing and I used
every excuse I could possibly think of
to avoid sitting down to write and this
is where I worked out a lot of the the
theories that are in my view of
creativity is that summer because
pressure is what causes creativity to
work best lack of pressure actually
works against creativity so as a
producer I'd much rather have a
low-budget film to deal with where every
single thing that you do has to be a
solution to the fact that you don't have
enough money to do it so it becomes more
creative and you tell the crew that you
know we have to have creative solutions
to these issues because money is not
going to solve this we don't have the
money
and of course studio films don't have
that issue they have endless pockets and
so on but nonetheless you can see that
if there was more discipline to them a
lot of them would be better than they
are
when you see a film that has six or
seven writers listed you know at the
beginning as screenwriters you know that
this was just caused by money you know
they they didn't work with writer number
three long enough they just fired him
and brought in writer number four and
that was the expensive way to do it and
but there's there's a challenge in the
pressure that comes and time pressure is
the number one pressure more than
financial even that works on behalf of
creativity if you only have a limited
amount of time I always found that I did
my most creative work half an hour
before committee meeting because I hated
committee meetings and I still find that
when I have to go to something that I'm
not wild about going to I have suddenly
extremely creative an hour before that
and rather than resenting that I my my
creativity around that so that that's
when I do it whenever I can and I think
that that's what we have to learn about
our minds is how to how to kind of trick
them into behaving the way we want them
to behave to producing what we want them
to produce so you talked about the type
C personality and then in your book how
to escape lifetime security and pursue
your impossible dream a guide to
transforming your career is it chapter
six a day in the life of type C and I
was wondering if we could talk about
that how is that
Dana life is it a structured day is it
well it's different from you know it's
going to be different for every type C
and it's going to be different from from
people who are not type C's and how it's
different is that the type C's
has learned how to arrange his day to
fit his type to fit his mind to fit his
or her mind
some people are night owls and some
people are you know early birds and the
early bird writer is not going to write
late at night because she not
comfortable writing in weight at night
she's comfortable in the morning so if
she gets up at 4 o'clock
she's gonna give herself as much time as
she has attention span for to do her
writing in the morning which is when I
love to do mine because no one
interrupts you from Florida to 7:00 in
the morning
but if you're an idol as toking was he
wrote Lord of the Rings completely after
one o'clock at night because he he was
so busy all the time
before then and had a family and
everything else so he wrote in the
middle of the night and sometimes he
wrote all night and just went to you
know went off to school to teach without
any sleep at all but that was okay
because he was doing what he loved so
his his day would be arranged
differently than you know the day of
someone who was on a clock that's not
their clock somebody wish to show up for
a nine o'clock job it's not on their own
clock and their day is going to be
probably one that they're upset with
most of the time whereas if you're you
know if you're type C and you in charge
of your own life you're gonna rearrange
it around the patterns that work best
for your mind and that I think that's
crucial part of becoming a Type C is
having your own kind of day okay I go to
a lot I go to meetings to sell the
properties that we've developed and I
don't like going to meetings because it
takes a lot of time to get there and
once you're there there's a certain
amount of wasted time and then you do it
the thing it's always fun you know even
though you dreaded it so I try to
arrange my day so that I'm doing
something that is very productive like I
always say I didn't get any work done
and my wife is telling me what are you
talking about you went to three pitch
meetings that's it you know - at three
different networks yeah I know but I
don't feel like I got any work done I
mean that's it's just your mental view
of things
and so I think that everyone's type
there every type C day is going to be
different and what you really need to do
is if you're interested in pursuing this
for yourself as you need to figure out
what is your ideal day I mean is it
important to you to go for a walk is it
to meditate is an important she to spend
next time on your creative work and is
it important to you to spend next time
with your family and all of those things
and you sit there and rearrange your day
to make that work that's what time
management is all about and how do you
do it you know no matter how busy you
are
there are busier people I was reading
Michelle Obama's book and nobody could
be busier than the President of the
United States and the First Lady of the
United States but somehow they they made
time for everything they needed to make
time for which tells you that there was
time management at work because
certainly if anybody had infinite things
to do an infinite work to do it would be
those two but if they can do it you can
do it too I think philip k dick loved to
write at night and he would stay up all
night and i'm not sure if some of it was
maybe chemically chemically induced but
then when he married another wife she
wanted him to write from nine to five
she said i'm very middle-class it was
why i liked these hours and so he
eventually got his own apartment what
she called the hovel and it was dirty
and he felt that he did his best writing
when when he wanted to in this you know
sort of dirty apartment and it just lent
to what he was doing so it's just
interesting how yeah you know world the
hubble syndrome is is interesting
because i think every creative person
can relate to that president obama
called his the hole and it was always a
room that had to be found in any house
they were in where nothing could be
touched you know he could do whatever he
wanted and usually there are papers all
over the floor and everything like it
was there that he finished a book or a
speech and so on and the hubble is the
same idea and i noticed that you know
i've always been the same way by the
weekend my office is a complete mess
there are things all over the floor and
and then by Monday it's all shipshape
and when you think about that it's
nothing but the externalization of the
creative process because the creative
process is making order out of chaos you
know in st. John's Gospel says in the
beginning was the word
and the Word was with God and the Word
was God
he was the beginning with God all things
were made through him you know and and
he goes on and talks about the light let
there be light etc so when when the
artist creates something he is taking a
bunch of little things and creating
order out of them and so the
externalized version of that is living
in a messy place and straightening it up
when as much as you have to whenever you
have to and if there's some external
force that is forcing you to straighten
it up then that creative person is not
in charge of their own life and they can
be you can always find a way to do it
there's a touching short story by Doris
Lessing called
to room 19 I think that's the name of it
- room 16 maybe in any case it's it's
one of her greatest short stories and
it's about a housewife who longed all of
her life to have a room of her own and
and it was because she couldn't she
couldn't be herself in her family and
she couldn't do what she wanted to do
and she didn't feel free and I won't
tell you how it ends
because it's not a fun ending but it's a
very tragic example of what happens if
you don't take charge of your own
creative life interestingly enough
Tolkien wrote a very introspective piece
called leaf by niggle strange title but
niggle was the name of a painter who had
this amazing vision of a spectacular
forest and his vision was so clear that
he could see every tree in the forest
clearly every animal in the forest every
leaf on every tree in the forest and
because he was so busy he never got
around to painting more than a single
leaf that's the way the story ends up
you know ends up and it's really
Tolkien's agonized argument for why he
had to write in the middle of the night
because he determined that he was not
gonna be niggle you know even though he
wrote something like four
books on linguistics and different
languages and of course Lord of the
Rings and The Silmarillion and many
other great works he felt that he had
barely gotten to one tree in his forest
and only that because he rode all night
so that that is a terrible thing to kind
of carry around is the the belief that
you can do amazing things which you
don't have time to do them and the
answer is that's not right you do have
time I mean where did Michelangelo find
his time where did Leonardo da Vinci
find his time you know they all had the
exact same number of hours that we have
and your job is to take your vision
seriously and find those hours to make
it happen or someone like Alice Monroe
who when she first started out was I
guess raising four children and she
didn't want the other housewives in the
neighborhood to know that she was a
writer because she thought she would get
the weird label which she ended up
getting and she didn't care anyway but
um I guess when you you win a Nobel
Prize it doesn't it takes all that away
but you know but she would do it when
the children were napping and if the
other housewives knocked on the door you
know she would put it all away she don't
want people to know but so I realized
that stigma is probably no longer today
no it's it's fill there is it yeah it's
it's it's a it originates in people's
families and and it's it's when you you
you announce to your father or your
mother that you're going to be a writer
or you're going to be a circus clown or
you're going to be a dancer or you're
going to be an actress and that is where
it starts because they you know the
normal responses are what are you gonna
do for a living and that haunt you
there's another but one of my books my
talk about learning as you go into the
creative life learning who your true
friends are and learning who your
friendly associates are because you lose
most of your friendly associates when
you make a decision to go from a
rational life to a creative life and
once they that class I gave a regular
class at UCLA that was called keeping
your spirits up for creative people
and one time there were a bunch of
actresses in the class and I said at the
beginning of the class I said let's go
around the circle and everyone introduce
themselves and tell me tell me your name
and where you're from and what is the
worst question that you could be asked
at a bar or a cocktail party in LA and
have you respond to it and when when
lady said you know she was from Arkansas
and her name was Joe and the worst
question that she had in LA was when he
gonna go back to Arkansas and work in
the post office again and I said howdy
we answered that that's terrible
and she goes usually by bursting into
tears and leaving the room and I said
well hopefully this class will find some
help for that the next woman said her
name was Jenny and she was from
California and she said and the worst
question that I have is what have you
been in big lately that I've seen and I
said yeah that terrible question - she
goes and I understood what is your
answer she goes the Pacific Ocean and I
always loved that because it showed that
here's a creative person who has figured
out how to protect her mind from the
inevitable things that are going to
happen in the big world people are not
born with sensitivity they don't walk
out of our homes on the way to a party
going I'm going to be particularly
sensitive today and the first thing they
say to an actress they meet us what have
you been in bigs that I've seen it's not
because they're mean or that they're
nasty people but maybe they are but it's
probably because they aren't being
sensitive and you having that answer
instantly bonds you with them and makes
them respect you for respecting yourself
enough to not take their questions
seriously you don't ever have to answer
any question that somebody gives you
unless you feel like it so when she
answers it that way she disarms the
whole situation whereas the first girl
is not doing such a good job because she
shouldn't be going to parties until she
can answer that question about going
back to Arkansas and working for the
post office and that's a
another example of protecting your mind
and not protecting your mind and having
the introspection to know how to deal
and you were talking about like whether
people react how do people react to
you're deciding to be creative you know
I always say it's it's like there's this
guy down the street who's been painting
in his garage for the last ten years and
you know when the neighbors are talking
they're talking about a mess he's crazy
you know he's a crackpot he's been doing
that for twenty years whatever and then
one day they read in the paper that one
of his paintings sold for a million
dollars and what did they what do they
say I always knew the guy was a genius
you know he had to be a genius to be
working that hard but everything
suddenly changes when the world accepts
your creativity but the only way you're
gonna get to that point is if you
absolutely control what you're doing and
believe in it yourself and even if you
don't believe in it keep acting as
though you do and in words you don't
have to believe in things you don't have
to feel good in order to work and you
don't have to feel good in order to do
good work you can work and normally when
you work you get rid of these feelings
anyway so this is all examples of
dealing with the creative mind and how
to get it to be your friend as opposed
to be something you're scared of and
don't want to take off to a cabin in the
woods well I noticed with the star is
born' which is now up for an Oscar we're
just about a month away or so that what
struck me about the film was the
loneliness of the creative process and
the lack of people around them when they
were working on things and whether it
was his drinking or whatever it was but
that it was so lonely and it was just
them and their material
yeah they had handlers around them and
dancers and different things but when
they were home it was it was very lonely
and I just thought that was very
interesting yeah it's a kind of
loneliness that you can't really
describe to people who are
part of it and so after a while you stop
trying to describe it maybe you go to a
shrink
to talk to the shrink about it at one of
my clients is a shrink for creative
people and probably half the people in
the Hollywood business go to him and and
they all have the same problems having
to do with the unbearable heaviness of
what they do and the fact that it is a
lonely process that no one understands
you like I'm a producer and people say
what does the producer do and I go I
have to give a like Pacific Ocean kind
of answer to that because it is a long
conversation and nobody understands it
and nobody's really that interested
anyway so it's it's just that's what
you're dealing with in the creative
world you're trying to articulate things
that are alien to most people who are
not living creative lives and it's it's
a burden to bear but it gets easier to
bear the more the light the more likely
you take it when you don't take it that
heavily when you have a dog or a cat or
you know something that you can it makes
you feel human if you cook like I love
cooking and I love playing tennis and
I'm not thinking creative thoughts when
I'm cooking or playing tennis I'm just
doing those things so I think that you
you you learn you you have to give
yourself a chance to be with your own
mind and figure it out and realize that
you know you can control it you know I
always think the creative mind has these
parts to it that the artist really needs
to be aware of and and the parts are
there's a great big bunch of it if you
imagine the mind like a big globe
there's a huge continent in the middle
of it that I call the continent of
Reason and it is all the established
things in your life it's your entire
education it's it's your ability to tell
time and how many languages you can tell
time it's even language because if you
weren't on that continent you would need
a language right if you weren't
communicating with millions of people
you wouldn't need languages so
that's orderly is from that continent of
reason and then there's these islands
all over the place that are each
individual and they don't have anything
to do with the continent and on those
islands strange things can happen those
are the like all the visionary islands
of a mind and the most most people are
trained as they're growing up when
they're when their parents talked them
out of being a painter and and talked
them into being a dentist you know or
talking them out of being a ballerina
and talked them into being a teller at
the bank you know those people are
trained to be members of the continent
to be good members of the society that
is the continent of reason where
everything is orderly where you show up
at nine o'clock you don't show up at
9:05 you know if you show up at quarter
to nine that's good but quarter after
nine that's the end of the job so those
people are raised that way and the
artist refuses to be raised that way he
wants to be he wants to visit all these
islands and he wants to somehow do
something with those islands and
eventually he wants to introduce those
islands to the continent because it
takes stuff from the continent like
language in order to write a story it
takes stuff from the continent like you
know color and lines and framing to be a
painter and if you don't know those
basic you know can conventions you can't
be a painter but you so you you learn
them but you your goal as an artist is
to make them different than anything
that's ever been on the continent before
right and eventually if you succeed and
just as jumping way ahead then what
you've done is now a part of the
continent if you're succeeded and and on
that I've never heard that's put more
eloquently than in a brilliant little
book called Picasso by Gertrude Stein
that everybody artistic should read
but one of the things she says in there
is every everybody thought that what
Pablo was seeing was different but he
was only seeing what he was seeing
he was not seeing what anyone else was
saying he was just seeing what he was
saying and after a while he started
painting what he was seeing and only
what he was saying
and before long suddenly we were seeing
what he was seeing and that kind of
explains the whole process by which an
original vision gets translated into a
classic you know Picasso was now
considered a classic painter in terms of
the history of art and and only because
he saw things differently
and had the courage and strength to
convey his vision and then finally his
vision started catching on because
somebody bought a napkin for a million
dollars you know and he was no longer
the crazy painter which he was
absolutely before that first cultural
breakthrough that commercial
breakthrough and that's that's part of
the excitement of it is to see how art
is changed culture by sticking to their
eccentric sort of anti cultural stance
we're talking about the artists is-is-is
anti cultural in the beginning because
he's pursuing his own private vision and
when his private vision begins to be
accepted by the larger culture then he
becomes an established artist and that
sounds good to the persons who live on
the continent of reason but to the
artist that becomes dangerous and and
and fraught with peril because he was
never interested in being like the
people on the continent and now he is
one of those people so what does he do
he goes through periods of his Picasso
you know he starts writing different
kinds of books if he's a writer
and his publishers don't like that
because they like him to write thrillers
because they they're part of the
continent of reason and they have
continent of reason invented pigeon
holes and niches you know find your
niche young man someone once told me
find your niche because I was trying to
do a magazine about dreams and the arts
and he was the editor psychology today
and that word niche is the continent
telling you you're too far out there you
know that's not going to work and okay
well we stubbornly continued my editor
my co-editor and I on and we created a
magazine that lasted for ten years
published in New York and so on but only
because we ignored him telling us to
find the niche but when we found that
niche you know we have to think of like
what are we gonna do next
and that's what Picasso has to think
about so he switches to his blue period
and switches to his cubist period and so
on
just because he's now competing with
himself
you know his part of the culture is now
earlier Picasso and that is a tremendous
burden for the successful artist to bear
think about Stravinsky whose greatest
works where his first works but the guy
lived to be you know 90 years old at the
right of the spring and and petrushka
and the Firebird suite were all written
when he was much younger so how does a
guy like that live through the next 40
years with great difficulty and
experimentation and and switching from
composing to conducting and lots of
other things he wasn't like he didn't
have a worthwhile life but he was always
nagged and haunted by the fact that his
art was in a sense premature when it
comes to healthy happy you know mental
development this is the kind of issues
that artists deal with and it's why a
lot of people are telling you don't do
that just work for the post office you
know work in a secure position didn't
work for you Kowski no it didn't he was
a good friend when he was around and I
he talked about hovels and Kay
so I once took my my five-year-old
daughter to his house to pick up
something because he was speaking in a
poetry series at Occidental College that
I was in charge of and she walked into
the house and she sat it at the top of
her voice
they had this the filthiest house I've
ever seen in my life and it's true there
was toilet paper on the floor there were
dirty dishes all over the floor it was a
mess but you know he wrote incredible
poems that moved everybody when I went
to Italy as a Fulbright professor I was
surprised to learn that rather than
Wallace Stevens and Hemingway all of
which I was prepared to teach in
Melville they only wanted to hear about
Bukowski his books were translated into
Italian all of them and he was you know
he was a mess
and he was his personal life was was a
mess and he kind of liked it that way he
never ran out of material to write and
he's one of the few who was able to
sustain a long career without feeling
trapped by his previous career he was
happy kind of doing what he was doing
over and over again I was talking about
publishers wanting a writer to
constantly do thrillers because that's
where his niche is and that's where he
should can do do thrillers but the
writer goes no I want to write mysteries
now I want to write romance the
publishers are not interested wait a
minute we've made six million dollars
out of you as a thriller writer and I
don't know if you know you could even
speak to the romance audience well I'd
like to try well okay then we're gonna
have to use a different name
so a typical response is for an artist
like keep them like Agatha Christie to
have four or five pen names and write
under many names Stephen King for
example because they want to write
different things they don't want to be
repetitive and forced their art into a
mold that is part of the continent of
reason and that's I've always seen that
those are the two big things going on at
the artists mind but then there's a
third thing which I call the managing
editor
which is the part of a mind that sees
this whole thing it's similar to you
know meditators till I knew that you
there's the third eye there's the
watcher that you have to develop to see
your thinking and to realize that it's
not you if there's more to you than just
the thinking well that's kind of what we
talked about in one of my books the
managing editor is the one who says I've
got to negotiate a deal between the
continent and the islands so that we can
actually get this book done because we
need things from the continent like time
which the continents in charge of
because on the islands there is no time
things happen all in at once and there
is no beginning middle and end just
everything happens at once but on the
continent that that's not allowed things
have to have a beginning a middle and
end in that order
unlike the Italian director who said
that movie didn't have to have a
beginning middle did have to have a
beginning middle in of it not
necessarily in that quarter he was
giving an island response to a continent
question and the question was does a
movie have to have a beginning middle in
it he goes yes but not in that order and
that's a the managing editor is the part
of your mind it sees this and goes okay
we're gonna negotiate if you say I'm
going to go to this cabin and write this
book no matter how long you know how
much it takes I'm gonna stay there until
it's done the continent freaks out
because it's going oh I'm gonna starve
to death like what's gonna happen if you
never finish the book what's gonna
happen so but but my intention editor
works out a deal and goes no we're only
gonna do two hours a day three hours a
day and then we're gonna do it for ten
weeks and at the end of that with that
many hours we're gonna be done and
here's the path so it could play as so
the continent is allowed to relax
because this intervening force has told
the crazy islands it wants to write this
book you guys can come out and do this
but you can only you're gonna have this
much time and blah blah blah
within this compartment and that's
that's what I think makes the same
artists as opposed to someone who's not
saying is working out deals like that
with themselves maybe not so formal
but that that's what they they do they
make bargains to keep their art going
well in the case of Bukowski the the
sort of slavery of his nine-to-five job
if you want to call it that was the
impetus for a lot of his stories and it
helped fuel him and it helped give him
that chip on his shoulder and sort of
put a voice is what so many people felt
so it's almost as if it worked for him
yeah and and well as Stevens who was one
of my favorite American poets and oddly
similar to Bukowski in a very
interesting ways was selling insurance
all of his life he was writing his
greatest poem like Sunday morning on a
train commuting from Hartford to New
Haven wearing a three-piece suit
because he was an insurance salesman and
that's what he had to do and TS Eliot
was working as a bank teller when he was
writing The Waste Land
so yeah ordinary jobs can be can be used
to spark creativity and the artists like
Bukowski in his later years found
himself more and more troubled when he
had an unstructured life and didn't have
to you know go anywhere
you